the lady playing Snow White she's got
another hit take it away you know the
original cartoon came out in 1937 and
very evidently
three
um with a guy who literally stalks her
weird weird
time so no Prince or a different kind of
Prince we have a different approach to
what I'm sure a lot of people will
assume is a love story just because like
we cast a guy in the movie Andrew burn
up great dude
um it's uh it's one of those things that
I think everyone's gonna have their
assumptions about what it's actually
going to be but uh it's really not about
the love story at all which is really
really wonderful and whether or not she
finds love along the way is anybody's
guess until 2024.
um all of Andrew scenes could get cut
who knows it's Hollywood baby you are
not gonna argue this type of person out
of misery